en el último vídeo esperamos haber
conseguido un conocimiento decente sobre
cómo funciona una función de valores
vectoriales o mejor aún una posición es
una función de posición que en cierto
modo es digamos un reemplazo a los
parámetros tradicionales de cómo se
escribe una curva verdad en este vídeo
quiero hacer una introducción al
significado de lo que es la derivada o
de cómo hacer una derivada de una
función de valores vectoriales en este
caso será respecto a un parámetro t así
que déjenme dibujar algunas cosas nuevas
por aquí digamos que tengo la función de
vectorial r dt ok que le ponemos con
flechita verdad y esto no es diferente a
lo que hice en el vídeo anterior esto es
x dt por y más 7 por jota donde y jotas
son nuestros vectores unitarios en la
dirección xy de verdad para además bueno
si quisiéramos hacer una curva en el
espacio agregaríamos una zeta de t por
cada verdad así que bueno esto describe
simplemente a una curva que está entre
los valores de t
qué te está entre los valores hay de
verdad severas y déjenme déjenme
esforzarme en dibujar algo algo
interesante voy a dibujar no sé curva
salazar por aquí digamos que la curva se
vería algo así
ok esto es cuando te vale ah y que irá
en esta dirección y hasta acá es cuando
te vale ve aquí es cuando vale a ok y
esto sería x de a y acá llegué a por
supuesto de este lado sería x bebé y acá
arriba estaría de bebé muy bien ahora lo
que vimos en el último vídeo que lo que
describe esta curva es son los extremos
de estos vectores de posición así que
esto es rda
esto es rda este vector es rda pero pero
lo que quiero pensar es cuál es la
diferencia entre dos puntos y digamos
vamos a [ __ ] dos puntos al azar y
algunos t al azar así que digamos que
este es r dt
ok voy a hacerlo de este lado y con
colores un color más agradable entonces
digamos que estoy aquí es r de alguna p
que alguna te concreta no sé cuál sea
pero es r de t
y ya sabes bueno no sé esto es alguna en
particular digamos que quiero yo saber
digamos cómo aumenta la función cuando
aumenta la t es decir vamos a ver qué
pasa con una r de temas h si vemos al
parámetro t como tiempo digamos que se
aumenta un poquito el tiempo en alguna
cantidad ahora vamos a estar por aquí
verdad aquí en amarillo este va a ser r
dt es más un período de tiempo h porque
hay un valor ligeramente mayor para h
ahora tenemos que preguntarnos qué tan
rápido que qué tan rápido es esta r
cambiando respecto a t ok entonces lo
primero que hay que decir es cuál es la
diferencia entre estos dos vectores si
yo si yo tomo estos dos y quisiera
visualizar la diferencia digamos aquí
tengo r que es nuestra posición a high y
lo evaluamos en temas h y de ahí hay que
restar r de t
esto es rd y que conseguiríamos tenemos
que revisar el álgebra de vectores
verdad pero básicamente conseguimos este
vector de remarcarlo con un color
agradable es este vector verdad es que
estoy pintando en magenta este vector en
magenta déjame déjenme déjenme ver esto
ok
este es r de temas h - r de verdad
ok ahora debe tener sentido porque
cuando añades los vectores es como
colocar el segundo en la cabeza verdad
es decir por ejemplo tenemos nuestro rdp
que es el verde más y si le sumamos este
morado que es r de temas h
- r de t es todo este vector cuando
cuando añadimos dos vectores en realidad
es como poner este segundo vector morado
en la cabeza del verde verdad entonces
cuando hacemos esto simplemente lo que
nos nos da como resultado es este
amarillo y como lo predije verdad va a
ser igual al amarillo que es r de temas
h y esto se puede ver fácilmente también
porque al que prácticamente se cancelan
los rd de verdad este y éste se cancelan
y van a cancelar sí espero que haya
quedado claro de cómo como encontrar la
dirección del vector tangente no estamos
diciendo este
en realidad estamos no estamos diciendo
que sea este vector verdad cuando
hacemos la resta en realidad es un
vector anclado en el origen como todos
los vectores pero bueno se puede
entender más o menos de esta forma así
que este individuo de aquí este vector
literalmente describe el cambio pero lo
que nos interesa es como bueno primero
déjenme desarrollar esto esto esto va a
ser igual
y esto es lo mismo que x de lo que dejen
de hacerlo déjenme hacerlo acá el primer
vector es x de temas h que multiplica a
nuestro vector unitario y
y también tiene ya de temas h que
multiplica el vector j
ok éste es sólo el primer vector todo
esto es el primer vector y ahora hay que
restarle rd t así que esta parte va a
ser menos lo podría ser acá pero vamos a
hacerlo acá abajo
- x dt ok por iu y menos aquí sería un
menos distribuyendo el signo menos 7 por
j
ok en realidad déjeme escribirlo de esa
forma no estamos restando este vector
que es r de verdad así que es este
individuo de acá así que tienes x dt por
y más 7 por jota y restamos todo este
vector verdad que es multiplicar por 1 -
además podemos revisar un poco sino si
no te acuerdas muy bien de qué estamos
hablando exactamente verdad revisa otros
vídeos sobre álgebra de vectores o qué
sé yo así que bueno yo creo que voy a
necesitar un poco más de espacio para
poder continuar con esto déjenme
escribirlo por acá
así que tengo r de temas h ok - r dt y
ahora estos voy a agrupar porque los
primeros dos vectores del amarillo y el
morado tienen como como componente ahí
entonces déjenme agrupar esto así que
tenemos x de temas h - x dt y todo esto
va a multiplicar a nuestro vector y que
es el vector unitario en la dirección x
verdad y ahora a continuación vamos a
sumar siete más h que le restamos 7 todo
esto lo agrupamos y multiplica al vector
unitario jota verdad sólo estoy re
ordenando las cosas por ahora y esto lo
que nos está diciendo es el cambio entre
estas dos eres verdad / r de temas h - r
de t donde aquí h es la cantidad que
aumentó el tiempo
ahora lo que quiero lo que quiero lo que
dijimos es que queríamos averiguar cuál
es el cambio instantáneo verdadero así
que lo que quiero ver es bueno cuánto
hizo este cambio durante un pero un
periodo de horas o de tiempo en lograr
en lugar de escribir h
pudimos haber escrito del tate pero
bueno aquí lo que hace falta es dividir
entre h lo que quiero decirle a mis
vectores cambian mucho pero quiero decir
que tienen que cambiar durante un
periodo de tiempo y esto es análogo a
dividir o utilizar el delta de verdad
aquí h es nuestro delta t ok este es el
cambio el cambio que hay por unidad de
tiempo así que lo que hay que dividir es
por h verdad aunque la diferencia entre
t y t + h es h así que vamos a dividir
todo entre h
todo entre h que estamos realmente
multiplicando un un vector por un
escalar simplemente o bueno en este caso
estamos dividiendo que en realidad es
nada más multiplicar o dividir cada una
de las componentes verdad así que para
cualquier diferencia h no se está
diciendo esta diferencia cuanto cambia o
cómo cambia el vector r verdad pero
bueno en realidad queremos hallar el
cambio instantáneo así que vamos a hacer
algo análogo a una pendiente como cuando
estábamos viendo los primeros vídeos de
cálculo y la ruta de acceso en cuestión
déjenme hacer un ejemplo más o menos
algo así digamos que fuera un trazo
lineal ok es decir si nuestro camino
fuera como una línea
en nuestro cambio promedio en digamos
digamos que tuviéramos dos vectores de
posición uno de ellos está aquí no no
tienen que ser necesariamente paralelos
verdad por ejemplo obtener ese y puedo
tener este otro ok y luego para
describir el cambio entre estos dos por
h o por unidad de tiempo
estamos calculando el cambio en nuestro
parámetro verdad esto es el h que
también podríamos considerarlo como la
del tate es la gente encuentra más fácil
escribir h verdad que la del tate pero
bueno de todas formas estoy preocupado
por el cambio instantáneo que estamos
tratando con curvas en general no
necesariamente líneas así que bueno
si queremos hacer esto podemos tomar
como en casos anteriores el límite
cuando h tiende a cero así que vamos a
tomar el límite de ambos de ambos lados
vamos a utilizar colores vibrantes para
para esto entonces cuando tomamos el
límite cuando h tiende a 0 de ambos
lados así que aquí también tomamos el
límite en este sumando y también en este
sumando cuando se tiende a cero lo que
quiero decir es bueno qué pasa o cuánto
cambia nuestro r por un cambio muy
pequeño verdad cuando la diferencia se
hace cada vez más y más y más pequeña
esto es exactamente lo que aprendimos
primero cuando calculamos la pendiente o
la velocidad instantánea verdad la
pendiente de una recta tangente bueno
esto parece un poco
esto parece como de la forma indefinida
verdad porque estamos dividiendo entre
un 0 digamos pero para suerte de
nosotros esta expresión de aquí es ya
muy conocida y de hecho es la derivada
verdad estamos multiplicando este es una
derivada multiplicando a un vector así
que esto es simplemente x prima de teo
la derivada de x respecto de esto de
aquí es de prima de t o bien la derivada
de g
respecto de así que de repente podemos
definir esta derivada de r como esta
derivada esta deriva esta derivada esto
es lo que vamos a llamar la derivada de
r r prima de t
ok que también podríamos llamar de rd te
aviso aquí es simplemente es es notación
pero bueno esta es su derivada y esto va
a ser igual
ok dejan escribirlo r prima de t es
igual a bueno esto que es la derivada de
x con respecto a t que es x prima de t y
que multiplica al vector unitario y
verdad más de prima de t que multiplica
al vector unitario jota en el sentido
vertical verdad es un resultado bastante
bonito y muy sencillo pero la cosa
difícil puede ser para en realidad la
cosa difícil está en que se aplica
verdad si pensamos en lo que sucede
permítanme hacer algo más gráfico sólo
para obtener la visualización de una
manera digamos saludable así que vamos a
decir que esta es mi curva y vamos a
decir que queremos averiguar el cambio
instantáneo de este punto justo aquí
rd te digamos y entonces si tomamos ere
de temas h lo vimos ya es eso digamos
puede ser un punto por acá esto puede
ser r de temas h ok ahora mismo la la
diferencia entre estos dos y esto es
sólo el número el vector que apunta de
rdr de temas h verdad ok esto es difícil
de visualizar aquí un poquito lo que va
a decir pero lo que quiero hablar es
sobre las magnitudes por ejemplo estos
dos la diferencia es este vector pero
luego cuando dividimos por h
si ay si pensamos que h es un número
pequeño digamos menor que uno vamos a
obtener un vector mayor verdad pero este
es el cambio promedio que tenemos pero
como se obtienen más pequeños y más
pequeños valores esta ere prima de t su
dirección va a ser tangente a la curva y
creo que si pueden visualizar esto estos
estos llegan a hacer más y más y más
cerca
la diferencia digamos la diferencia se
hace cada vez más pequeña sin embargo al
multiplicar por nuestra h la magnitud
del vector cambia la dirección en la que
se va aproximando cada vez más a la
tangencial a una tangente a la curva
verdad pero entonces como les decía
estamos también dividiendo por una h muy
pequeña es decir estamos tomando el
límite de h cuando h tiende a cero
entonces a lo mejor la magnitud de este
vector es difícil de visualizar pero
puede variar verdad y esa magnitud va a
ser dependiente de la parametrización de
la curva la dirección es la que depende
de la forma ok la magnitud no depende de
la forma depende de la parametrización
entonces r prima es tangente a la curva
o podrían imaginar que este vector está
sobre la línea tangente a la curva la
magnitud de la misma es un poquito
difícil de entender y voy a intentar
darle intuición en el siguiente vídeo
pero esto es lo que quiero que ustedes
entiendan ahora mismo porque vamos a
utilizar esto en el futuro cuando
hagamos integrales del link
sobre funciones con valores vectoriales